vous pas que des paroles mais deux mois
25 la lutte contre le gaspillage et le
travail quotidien et d'andrée anne
lorrain la copropriétaire d'une épicerie
zéro déchet à montréal surveille une
tendance dans les supermarchés de grande
bretagne comme quelques autres
l'entreprise anglaise waitrose annonce
qu'en septembre des centaines de
produits sur ses étagères dont des
fruits n'auront plus la mention meilleur
avant c'est ça que d'enlever les dates
de meilleure avance sur des productions
pas nécessaire ça permet vraiment
députés une partie du gaspillage
alimentaire le gaspillage est un
problème mondial au canada plus de 2
millions de tonnes d'aliments sont
gaspillées par les ménages canadiens par
année 63 % de la nourriture jeter aux
poubelles aurait pu être consommée et
plus de 1300 $ d'aliments sont jetés par
un ménage moyen annuellement
mais ce ne sont pas tous les
consommateurs qui laisserait tomber le
meilleur avance sur les aliments pour
autant il faudrait qu'il égalerait ainsi
que c'est vraiment affreux moi ça me
dérange pas obliger un peu l'habitude de
flairer les les escomptes pour les trucs
qui sont près de la date de péremption à
mon avis ça ferait pas de différence
pour moi pour certains l initiative et
écologique pour d'autres elle est avant
tout économique
si ces détaillants là le fond c'est en
grande partie parce que évidemment la
grande bretagne comme le canada passe
par une forte inflation et en ce moment
tout le monde essaie de réduire les
coûts notamment les coûts d'opération
mais également les coûts de gaspillage
chez le consommateur les supermarchés
sont ouverts à de nouvelles règles sur
l'étiquetage des aliments croit le
président de l'association des
détaillants en alimentation du québec
peu importe ce qu'il veut et écrit sur
le paquet c'est important de pouvoir
donner la bonne information
consommateurs selon le site web du
gouvernement canadien la mention
meilleur avant ne garantit pas la
salubrité du produit mais donne des
renseignements sur la fraîcheur et la
durée de conservation potentiel des
produits non couverts en retirant cette
indication de certains produits
l'entreprise britannique waitrose france
éviter le gaspillage
2 7 millions de paniers de nourriture
ici charles du boullay radio canada
montréal